so I'm president of the University of
Pennsylvania and I run a university that
I'm very proud of that is not only on
the forefront of research and teaching
and has 12 professional schools and arts
and sciences all on one beautiful campus
but I'm also the head of a university
that's the largest private employer in
Philadelphia second only to the
government we're the largest employer
and I do it for so many reasons it's
everything I believe in rolled into one
it enables me to further education and I
think there's nothing more important to
the 21st century than higher education
enables me to give opportunities to the
best and the brightest kids from low and
middle-income families from all over the
world this year we admitted 13 and a
half percent international students to
Penn last year we started a new
scholarship policy that eliminated loans
for kids from American families who have
incomes of under sixty thousand dollars
and we doubled the number of those kids
at Penn it enables me to create economic
opportunities in Philadelphia where in
China and India enables me to also
engage globally so there's almost no
limit but the resources we have to what
we can do as a great university so imma
I'm very privileged I'm very it's a
culmination of a lot of what I believe
well I wouldn't call it a struggle of
being a president I'd say they're
endless challenges to being a president
of a large research university
everything from how do you create more
opportunities for people against the
backdrop of increasing inequality in
this country such that kids from low and
middle-income families really don't have
the same opportunities as kids from
affluent families and that that concerns
me a lot there's the fact that it is a
fact that government in Washington
doesn't really understand hire it what
our mission is and so there's the threat
of putting a standardized test on all of
higher education which would really move
us backwards rather than the four so
there's the the challenge of raising
money to do more and more research and
we have a hospital system in a medical
school that's doing you know life-saving
and life-enhancing research and there
it's very resource intensive so there's
the challenge of arguing as well as for
more funds from Washington as well as
raising more money and then there's the
challenge of becoming more global which
i think is a great opportunity but it is
a challenge as well
it takes everything you have and then
some I think I you know before
multitasking was a word I think I was a
multitasker and I think all successful
presidents of universities multitask we
have constituencies that range from
wonderful students undergraduates as
well as graduate and professional
students to faculty and alumni and we
have to be available to all of them so
have to love people have them be able to
be a visionary articulate your vision
know how to implement it know how to get
all those constituents to not think
they're following you but actually that
there with you because faculty are not
followers faculty are very autonomous
and independent researchers and teachers
and they have to share my vision and
that's why one of the first things I did
as president in my inaugural was
announced a compact it's a social
compact we call it the pem compact and
it's our vision for moving ahead and it
says we're going to increase access
we're going to integrate knowledge
across domains so we can address social
problems and we're going to engage
locally and globally and that's our
vision we have lots of ways of putting
it into effect and without that and
without the buy into that I couldn't be
successful oh I don't know what I'm best
known for I think the compact is the
overarching theme that is attached to my
presidency at 10 and I think it's part
of what I'm known for and I'm you know
one of the reasons i like it is that I'm
a political philosopher and when I came
to the presidency I thought what is it
about Who I am as a person and what I am
as a scholar and teacher that can make a
difference at Penn and it struck me that
there's a great social contract
tradition info
philosophy from John Locke whom the
founding fathers were inspired by to
John Rawls who was one of my teachers at
Harvard and if I could use that in a way
that resonates in a university we could
have the pen compact a social contract
which drove us forward we'd never
entirely realize it but we'd always know
what what we were doing and why and so I
guess it is a projection of my core
convictions on to a much larger stage
than I could have ever had as a scholar
and a teacher